[Music]
it's become as much a part of james
bond's identity as a shaken martini
the aston martin db5 has provided bond
with a much-loved iconic car since
1964. albeit one-armed with machine guns
and ejector seats
now that car is being faithfully rebuilt
for collectors with a price tag
of 3.5 million bucks charlie dagetta
went to aston martin's headquarters
outside of london
to take a drive
for even casual james bond fans
this car needs no introduction because
nothing says 007 more than the silver
birch 1964 aston martin db5
chief creative officer mark reichman
recalls the moment that db5
popped up in the last spawn movie
spectre there was a cheer in the theater
you know it's like great bond is back in
the db5 yet again
as an aston martin man what did that
feel like the
feeling of wow you're part of history
and it's very much the same with db5
we're part of a legend db5 is a legend
and this all original db5 is brand
spanking new fresh off the assembly line
one of just 25 built wow and at a price
tag
of 3.5 million dollars
sure it's a gorgeous car even by 007
standards
but there's something about the db5
that's
just timeless from the first moment sean
connery's bond tossed it around in
glorious technicolor
in its debut in 1964's goldfinger
the car has outlasted every actor to
ever play bond
starring in seven films already and
counting
the cameo with pierce brosnan stop this
car
at once in 1995's golden eye
[Applause]
[Music]
resurrected in 2012 skyfall
it's not very comfortable is it
are you going to complain the whole way
i'll go i'm going to jet me
see if i can including scenes that
weren't just a gentle joy
and it'll show up again in no time to
die
this fall's upcoming bond release
it's outlived many bonds because it has
a stronger character
and visually it's got that character
it's got eyes it's got a face
it has a language and it has a presence
the new old db5s are continuity cars
not replicas each one painstakingly
handmade
using the very same materials and
techniques including
the lightweight aluminum body i mean to
say this is a lost art
doesn't really go far enough and to call
charlie briggs
a panel beater doesn't go far enough you
want to sort of
caress the material into shape as
opposed to bashing it into shape
that's the real artist
and after all that caressing it takes
400
hours just to paint a single car
you'll be using this aston martin db5
now if you take the top off but of
course a bond car
wouldn't be a bond car without gadgets
fire the passenger ejector seat
evolving number plates naturally so the
new db5s have been equipped with
simulated toys too
as chief executive paul spyers
enthusiastically demonstrated
so if i'm being pursued by the bad guys
and i want to uh
smoke them out
okay can you show me the machine guns
machine guns that's awesome
seriously with the 3.5 million dollar
price tag in mind for a car whose fake
machine guns mean it's not even street
legal
that's it it was time to get the full
bond experience oh it's such a fun car
it's it drives like an old car
it was the lap of luxury at the time and
smells like leather
and musk and testosterone with a hint of
shaken martini
i could see where sean connery uh how he
kept fit all you needed to do was drive
this exactly it handles like a 56 year
old car ought to
not that i was allowed to play with any
of the gadgets now can i press the
button for the all slaves no
absolutely not
and when it was over you begin to
understand
why it's been so hard for any bomb to
say goodbye
i thought you'd gone i have
[Music]
there's just one thing i need
for cbs this morning saturday charlie
dagetta
london
we're all just singing along here right
what a toy what a toy
i have been a bun girl since eighth
grade
seen every film so i am ready
the machine guns
that's true